NEWS, THE TOPREPUBLICAN IN THEE
E
S HE IE SE
JU IS ONT" WIT
WHO ISN  LIST?
>> Reporter: SOME OFHESTAUNCHES
PRESIDENT DONALD TRU
THESE MEN WHICH
THAN LEADER HAD NOT O S
TH DRATS
.
EIGHT MEMBERS SELECTED SEVEN AR
E REICAN LIZT
FIVE REPUBLICANSPPOINTED NOW
BY THE REPUBLICAN LEADER THA
UDESESSMAN JIM BANKS.
HE WILBEDING THERAE
F  AND
Y ARMSTRONG OF N
ANTEXAS.OF THOSE MEMBERS TO
CETHE JANUARY 6th ELEC
THY
WELL AS ROEY
THHE
OVERTURN THE ELECTORAL RESULTS
D TWO OF THOSE MEMBERS, JIM
SIGNETHE TEXAS T THAT WOULD  I
VOTES ACRO
T INO
OF THEM JIM RDASKED WHAT
DO REPUBLICANS WANT TO ESTABCOM?
HE SAID THIS IUSED  ATTACDOBLAN.
IS TT FOR A VSATO IEVERYTHINGN
FORMER PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS A
THE PUATEA
OFM  TS MAKING
CLEAR HE VIEWS THIS AS
TO GAFTER DONALD TRUMP WILL DEF
PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS.
WETH
THE FIRST HEARG BEFORE THIS
THEY DECIDE TO INVESTIGATE OTHE
HEAR ANYTHIN STHING,
EVEN THOUGH THEY LIVED THROU SHE
IS JUST ABOUT TAKINGNALDIN THATG
SO THE
JOB THEN ISO DEFEND NALD TRU A
COMMIT ALREADY SETTINGP
FOr: WELL,M JORDANAD
JUST
MOMENTS AGO AND BEENG
BEGINNING AND PART
JANUARY OVEN E
6th.
HE VOTE  DO THAT AND
A STAUNCH DEFENDER OF
DONALD TRUMP FROM THE
ANRS OTT
BEEN SI
THEY WANT TO GO AFTER NANCY
DIDD NOT
DO TO SECU THAT
HE FOCUS OF
THE REPUBLICAN A CE.SO YOU'ROW N
TSIDE COMMISGOING
CONTENDED THAT WILL BEILTICS BU
AT
E SUGGESTING
>> SPEAKER PELOSI HAS VETO
IS SHE GOING TO USE THIS HERE?
>> THALEE MOMENT
THEY SAY THEY'RE REVIEWING WHA
ER HAS
CO U.
THE REPUBLEADER SIESS CAN
Y ESSENTIALLY NO, SHE WILL N
ALLOW THESMEARD BUT IF STO DO WO
'SAR IF SHTA MEMBER
OM SIDE ON A SELT
COMME.THIS IS PIL PROCESS THAT
IS DONE HERE BUT SHEOE
LIEVE SHE SHOULD UT AND LEAR WH
HERSF WILL DO.  THANKS SO MUCH.
GREAT REPORTING, AS ALWAYS.
>>> EIGHT MONTHS IRAL
FE A JANUARY
RIOTER.EAR-OLD PAUL HOG K
TRE CAPITOL FROM
JALL STAND DOWN AND RS HAD KER L
TH A NEXT
"OUTAN FED
PROSECUTOR.
T DO YOU THINKF
SENTENCE?
>> KATE, I THINK IT'S
TH WITHITHE RANGE OF
REASON OUTCOMET
IT'S LIGHT.
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF HE
MO
PROSECUTORS DON'T ALWAYS GET
.N , MANY PEOPLE JUDGE GAV
COMMIT LESS SERICRIMES TN
THIS AND DO SIGNY MORE
TIME THAN EIGHT
ON KEY
RPF SENTENCING IS DE
A MESSAGE T
THISONS AN,  NOT BECAUSE THE LA
OWN ON
I DON' EIGHTNTH
SENTENCE MEETS THAT GOAL.
DEPARTMENT H CED ANY RIOTEITH S.
HAPPENING ANT AND
CHARGED WHHAACD  TST OF THOSE PE
E PEOPLE THAT D ACTS OOLENCE
ALMOST CERTAINE AND SIGNIFICANT
BUT NONG SEDITION.I DON'T THINK
TODAY'S CHARGES ARE
THEY WERE CHARGED
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS.
ON DEFITTHE
IM SEDITION IS INTERFERING
OR OBSH TH